all right
uh Bill Maher has gotten himself in
trouble with the left yet again for a
monologue he delivered on his show on
Sunday
and he's being accused because of this
what you're about to hear because of
these remarks he's being accused of um
of white supremacy and and actually
justifying slavery but let's listen and
find out if that is a fair
characterization
did Columbus commit atrocities of course
but people back then were generally
atrocious
foreign
everybody who could afford one had a
slave including people of color
the way people talk about slavery these
days you'd think it was a uniquely
American thing that we invented in 1619
but slavery throughout history has been
the rule not the exception the Sumerians
the Egyptians the Greeks Romans the
Arabs British the early Americans all
the way up through R Kelly
foreign
[Applause]
the Holy Bible is practically an owner's
manual for slaveholders the word slave
comes from slav
because so many Slavic people were
enslaved and they're as white as the
Hallmark Channel
who do you think gathered the slaves
from the interior of Africa to sell to
slave Traders Africans who also kept
their own slaves
uh and the whole monologue is quite good
it goes on for about eight minutes it's
worth listening to putting aside the dig
at the Bible there which is silly and
not true
the rest of it
I basically agree with and it's also not
true that people back in in earlier
times were generally atrocious it's not
like they weren't worse people but they
lived in a different time they lived in
a more brutal time but generally
speaking the message there I agree with
it in fact it might remind you of
something it might remind you of a
monologue that I delivered on this show
very recently you know it's very similar
now I'm not accusing Bill Maher of
listening to my show I would never
accuse anybody of that but we have had a
similar conversation and I'm glad that
Mars talking about it it's important
because it helps us to actually
understand
historical events when we put them in
context
right you can't you can't understand
anything about history until you
understand the context
of the people that you know the the
context that people lived in back in
those days it's funny in fact that the
left
cares deeply about context
when we're discussing say the brutality
of modern day criminals non-white
criminals anyway
so if we see another one of those videos
of uh some someone who's out on bail and
has a lengthy rap sheet just randomly
brutalizing someone or there was one
recently of a
someone robbing a convenience store
and putting the the cashier on his knees
and then executing them shooting in the
back of the head
of course that person lengthy rap sheet
criminal I think that person was out on
on bail I believe
many videos like that whenever we see
these videos what we hear from the left
is that um well we have to understand
the context we have to understand it the
systemic racism and and all the things
that they've suffered in their Community
we have to understand that
and the context becomes an excuse that
lets the criminals off the hook and back
into the community to victimize even
more people
but then somehow they're totally
uninterested in analyzing the context
for anyone who lived on earth prior to
the Modern Age so people that are living
today some people anyway get the benefit
of context
but nobody who lived before us gets gets
the same
Grace
they're all expected to just know better
but with that attitude you can never
understand history and if you refuse to
understand history then it's it then
studying it is pointless and impossible
there's another reason why this matters
also it's that
uh
you know it can give us an opportunity
to analyze ourselves
like the fact that everyone in the world
supported slavery
for thousands of years
that almost no one voiced any objection
to the practice in principle now there
were people who objected to certain
elements of the practice and and
objected when it was particularly brutal
but as far as someone saying slavery
itself is wrong
human beings are all equal like that
sort of thing there was almost no one
making that claim for thousands of years
of human history across the entire world
and that fact ought to make us reflect
on ourselves because it goes to show how
powerful
a dominant cultural narrative can be you
know it's the power of of the spirit of
the age
if everyone accepts something
everyone is does and nobody questions it
then it's very difficult to view that
thing in a critical light
because you don't have you haven't been
given the framework
for being critical of it
everything you've ever encountered every
opinion you've ever heard
everything around you serves to
reinforce this cultural narrative
and this force is so powerful that it
even protected slavery from criticism
for millennia
now
I think a lot of modern people they tell
themselves
they say themselves well
if I was born 500 years ago I would have
known better
everyone that existed in the world for
thousands of years they were all morons
if only I was there I would have told
them I would have known
but you almost certainly would not have
known better because you only know now
that slavery is wrong because everyone
you've ever met from from birth onwards
believes it was wrong and told you that
you were told from birth that it's wrong
you didn't you didn't you don't you
don't get any credit for that Revelation
other people had that Revelation and
it's correct it's a it's a it's a
correct rep and they passed it on to you
they told you
everything in your life reinforces the
idea that slavery is wrong thankfully
so given that you've existed in this
context it's just meaningless to declare
that you would have arrived at the same
conclusion had the context been exactly
the opposite of what it is today
now the point here is not relativism
okay it's not that um
it's not that uh slavery was okay back
then because everyone thought it was
if you're a relativist then that would
have to be your conclusion we're going
to talk more about relativism in the
daily cancellation but if you're
actually a relativist and if you believe
we all get our own truth and there's no
objective truth then you then you of all
people have no basis for condemning
anyone really but especially people in
history and especially when it comes to
something like slavery because it was
their truth that slavery was okay who
are you to say otherwise
but I'm not a relativist I believe that
there are there is objective truth and
objective moral truth
um and it was objectively wrong even
then
but the point again is just to
understand the power of a dominant
cultural narrative so
here's one way
to know
that you would not have opposed slavery
if you're asking yourself would I have
opposed slavery if I if I lived 500
years ago or 200 years ago or a thousand
years ago
well here's one way to know that you
would not have opposed it
if today all of your views and beliefs
and ideas
and opinions line up perfectly
with like Disney
and Apple
and Hollywood movie studios
and the people who run Twitter and
Facebook
okay if everything you believe lines up
perfectly with those organizations and
and and what they profess
then you would have supported slavery
a thousand percent certain that you
would have how do I know that because
because you are the sort of person who
simply accepts and adopts whatever ideas
are dominant and popular and supported
by the cultural institutions of the day
it's it's not a coincidence it just it
just happened to be that you that your
point of view your world view lines up
perfectly with all of the dominant
cultural institutions
no it's a they told you and they are the
dominant cultural institutions they're
the most powerful institutions in the
country they've told you what to believe
and you believe it
and if that's the case then it only
stands to reason that if you had lived
in a time when all the most powerful
cultural institutions said that slavery
was okay you would have believed that
too
now the powerful cultural institutions
say that uh that women have penises men
can give birth to babies there are lots
of people in this country say well I
guess that's the case then
Twitter wouldn't lie to me about that
well before you go uh hit the Subscribe
button and ring the bell and while
you're at it if you want to go watch or
listen to my full show head to
dailywire.com And subscribe you can also
catch my show on Spotify Apple podcast
or wherever you get your podcast so go
check it out now I demand it
your compliance is somewhat appreciated